more than 44,000 utility customers in
Wilmington alone are without power the
city will feel the impact of Lawrence
throughout the weekend meteorologist
Megan Glaros of our Chicago station
wbbm-tv is on the road tracking the
storms forecast Megan good morning yeah
good morning Janet I am not surprised
we're having a hard time getting Jeff's
signal out to you guys and the reason
for that is because we were just in the
eyewall of Hurricane Florence the most
intense winds the most intense rain rain
was coming in sideways but as we drive
around right now I think we might be in
the actual eye of the hurricane at the
moment if we can take this radar in a
little bit tighter it's calmed down
significantly now we still have
obviously some rain coming down but it
appears to me that we may actually be in
that I wall the National Hurricane
Center watching they'll put out an
official statement a little bit later on
this morning once they have full
confirmation but once that center of
circulation passes Overland that's when
we are considered in a landfalling
situation looks like it may be right
around Wrightsville Beach which is just
to the east of Wilmington along the
coastline that's where we were live for
evening news a couple nights back so at
this point we still have inclement
conditions very clearly but it's a
little bit lighter than it was just a
while ago but still looking at some of
those intense bands now even when we're
in the eye of the hurricane here we've
got the best out of it do you get that
front side coming through then the back
side has to come through eventually the
eye at one point was about 20 to 25
nautical miles wide
so that's the duration of time where
you'd have it a little bit calmer but
right now obviously the winds are coming
in still a sort of fierce at this point
rain has been going now for hours it was
going all night last night it will
continue through the day today
in my estimation that's going to be the
biggest problem yes right now as we
drive around you can see there are tree
limbs down the cars being buffeted a bit
by the winds again right now it's a
little calmer than it was but we are
certainly looking at the potential for
this rain to continue for a long period
of time we're talking about all day
today we're talking about all day
tomorrow and we're likely talking about
moving into at least a portion of the
weekend gale
so at the moment a little better than it
was but we've got the backside of this I
that'll come through it a little bit of
time here in Wilmington Meghan this
morning I heard that had gone from a
category four to a category one and I'm
thinking of what we're looking at is a
category one I would hate to see what a
category four it looks like I said that
exact thing this morning when I looked
outside everything was coming in
sideways Gale the winds and the real
issue with this storm I think not so
much the wind though it's going to be
the rain so after the fact that's going
to be still capped for impacts from rain
where the winds are a little bit lighter
than they would have been previously all
right Megan thank you very much